now uh our next speaker is joanna perkup
who is going to tell us about fast
reinforcement learning with generalized
policy updates
so please do not take it away thank you
very much and before i start i just want
to say
thank you to the organizers of this
workshop i found the schedule
uh really inspiring and interesting uh
this whole week and uh
it's really nice to have this in in
these difficult circumstances
uh so i will talk about a recent pianist
paper actually
uh and this is joint work with andre
barato
diana borcha and david silver my
colleagues at deepmind
um and the motivation for this work
is really uh that we would like to have
reinforcement learning agents
that become uh generally capable ai
agents
and i always use cooking as an example
you know partly because
i would like other people to do more
cooking for me perhaps
uh but also uh because i i find it a
good illustration
of this idea uh that you need to have
agents that can quickly
uh adapt to unforeseen circumstances uh
and can improvise
and learn how to do things with very
little uh new data
so ideally we would like to have
reinforcement learning agents
uh that can build policies and can
can build uh predictions uh over time uh
and then reuse them
uh as necessary so just to give you an
example it's about to be
my my daughter's birthday uh and my
youngest daughter wanted to bake her a
cake but as it results we have no flour
in the house
um and so now she has to uh improvise
something that is kind of like a cake
but
involves no flour which is one of the
main ingredients
and she's actually doing a great job of
that i have to say
um but a reinforcement learning agent
may not be able to do this
and so um the work that i'm going to
talk about
is trying to move us in the direction of
having reinforcement learning agents
that can easily transfer their knowledge
recombine their knowledge
in the face of a changing world and in
the face of unexpected circumstances
and in order to do this we're going to
build on the foundation of policy
evaluation and policy improvement which
are in some sense the bread and butter
of all dynamic programming algorithms
and so by extension also reinforcement
learning algorithms
so imagine you have a markov decision
process uh you have some policy pi
and this markov decision process uh
policy evaluation and policy improvement
you can think of these as
two operators uh that map between
policies and value functions
so policy evaluation takes a given
policy pi
and computes the associated value
function whether over states or
over action state action pairs q
and policy improvement is going to take
a value function
and then compute out of it an improved
policy
by using a maximization operator
and when we do policy improvement we
have quite an interesting guarantee
which says that the new policy obtained
denoted pi prime in these slides is
better than the old policy pi
that we had at all states now you're
going to notice here in the slides that
i'm using the standard notation
except i've put a subscript to all the
value
functions a little r subscript um r
denotes the reward function
and this is going to come in handy
because i would like to think
about generalization
for different reward functions and so
we're going to parameterize our
later so dynamic programming we often
have a model of the environment and we
then do policy valuation and policy
improvement exactly and
interleave these steps in reinforcement
learning we don't have a model of the
environment
and so we do approximate policy
evaluation and approximate policy
improvement
and again interleave them somehow
and so this is just a picture to sort of
visualize what's going on
you know an agent might start at a
policy pi one here
policy valuation takes by one and maps
it into the space of value functions
and then policy improvement takes a
value function and maps it back into a
policy
um and so these pa these steps will be
interleaved and eventually
if we have a finite markov decision
process and we have a perfect model
we'll end up with an optimal
uh policy pi r star and an optimal value
function for this particular
reward function and the other picture
here
the square picture is a similar
visualization
but just in value space um and we have
only two states
and so any particular value function is
a dot here in this square
and the orange trajectory is the orange
trajectory through value space okay so
if we start with the value of some
particular policy pi one
and we do policy improvement we will end
up with a policy pi
2 that has to be in this shaded area
because it has to be better at all
states
and so one way to think about policy
improvement is that we have these
sort of squares or rectangles that are
included in each other and eventually
we'll end up with with the optimal value
function
vr stuff so what i'm going to do in this
talk is actually to generalize this
process
both to multiple reward functions so
multiple
r's as well as multiple policies pi
okay so this is going to lead us to
generalized policy evaluation and
generalized policy improvements
i'll describe these operators and
they'll show some empirical results uh
that use this type of method
um and you know why would we want to do
this well multiple policies might be
learned by the agent during its lifetime
ahead of time and so if we have a way to
combine the knowledge in these policies
uh very quickly that might be useful and
multiple reward functions
is something that is of course very
useful for multi-task learning where you
have an agent that's always in the same
uh dynamics right the probability
distribution stays fixed but the reward
changes over time
um but a different way to think about it
is even if you have a
a fixed environment that is really
really big
where the agent has uh sort of trouble
uh traveling everywhere at some point it
might end up in some new states and
that's as if you had
a new reward function
so what are generalized policy updates
we're going to
do generalized policy evaluation and
generalized policy improvement and these
are going to be
very similar to the ones that we do with
single policy and single reward function
specifically generalized policy
valuation is going to compute the value
of some policy
but for an entire set of reward
functions
okay so capital r here denotes the set
of reward functions
um generalized policy improvement is
going to take a set of policies big pi
and some given reward function and
compute a new policy pi
prime that is better than what we had
before
for this specific reward function
and so the uh the guarantee here
that we have is very related to the one
we had for usual policy improvement
except we have an added suprema over the
space of policies here okay so the
guarantee
is that the value of pi prime is going
to be better
than the value that i would have
obtained with any of the policies in my
given set
um and of course if we just have one
reward function r and one policy pi
then we just recover usual policy
valuation and policy improvement
so let's let's uh visualize a little bit
what what's going on here so
we're going to have a space of policies
big pi over here there
for example there are two policies in
myspace right now
there's also a space of possible value
of possible reward functions big r
and in this particular case there are
three different reward functions in this
space
gpe generalized policy evaluation
computes the value
of one policy say pi one in this case
in all of these different tasks and i'm
going to talk in a minute about how we
can do this efficiently
in certain cases uh
gpi the policy improvement operator
lives in one of these tasks
and it's going to take
value functions for multiple policies
and compute something that is better
than all of them not necessarily optimal
okay
and so for the for example if you look
at task r1
uh what does this guarantee mean it
means that if i have these two value
functions these two rectangles
gpi is guaranteed to give me something
that's inside their intersection okay
now you know in the middle you have a
situation where the
the policy is actually one of them is
better than the other in that case
uh gpi is not going to do anything
except select the better policy okay
and of course ideally i would like to be
in a situation like in task
three where the space that i end up with
here is very very small right this means
that i've done
a lot of improvement
okay so so this is sort of the intuition
of what we're going to do we now have to
spell out a little bit more about how
we're going to carry out
the gpe and gpi these these two
different operators
um and the first thing that that we're
going to talk about is
a generalized policy evaluation
and the intuition that we're going to
use here is that
if there was a way to describe the
reward function
r and then to have a nice mapping
from r to q pi r for any pi
then actually generalized policy
evaluation would be very efficient we
would learn this mapping
right and then we could just use it
uh and we could very easily evaluate uh
a policy a given policy pi for any
reward function
uh now you know this is going to be hard
to do in general
but assume for example that the reward
is actually
linear in some kind of feature space phi
okay
so the reward function can really be
described by a parameter vector w
uh and the reward of any state is just
w dotted with the features of that state
so then the space of all the word
functions r phi is just described by the
space of these parameters w
now phi could be very complicated phi
could be i don't know the
first layers of a comp net or something
like this
but the dependence of the reward is is
only linear here
so in this case we already know
from uh the prior work of andre barreto
and colleagues
that there is a nice way to represent
the value function by using successor
features
okay so successor features are
the expected value of the feature
vectors
accumulated and discounted over time
okay so
psi pi of a state action pair is just
accumulating the feature vectors
phi of all the state action pairs that
are coming afterwards
discounted okay and this is just like a
regular
value function can be estimated for
example by td methods
and there are some interesting special
cases of this
for example the successor representation
of peter diane
is obtained here if phi is just a one
hot indicator
now if we compute the successor features
then actually
uh the value function for any particular
linear reward uh q pi
w here can just be obtained by taking
w and dotting it with the successor
feature representation
and this is again work that's been done
by android
and colleagues that appeared in europe's
uh a few years ago
so this is now a special case where we
can do policy evaluation very quickly
uh basically by uh taking our
reward function and mapping it using
successor features
into a value function the successor
features will need to be pre-computed
but we can do this once at the beginning
of time for policy pi and then we can
use them thereafter
this is again under the assumption that
the transition dynamics of the
environment
stay the same note also that the
successor features are actually a form
of model
uh of the environment because they sort
of encode this expectation but over
over the dynamics now how are we going
to do
a generalized policy improvement well
this is actually pretty easy
it's just like the the policy
improvement operator that you normally
have
except instead of just taking a max over
actions we're also going to take a max
over policies in our policy class
and for the purpose of this talk i'm
only using discrete policy classes so i
have two
three four policies so actually taking
this max here
is not going to be very expensive i
think
if the policy class is is complex then
maybe this
uh this operation needs to be thought of
a little bit more
okay so so this is just the the usual
almost the usual policy improvement
i want to make a couple of remarks one
is that
um pi prime may end up
because of this this arg max choosing
actions that are not actually chosen by
any of the policies in the policy class
right so for example if in my policy
class i have two policies
that are attracted to some area of state
space
the arc max if what i want is to be
repulsed by another reaction
state space will be some other action
okay
and so there is no sense in which pi
prime is limited by the choices that are
that are in pi
um the other interesting aspect of this
is that this
process is actually going to be done
after one iteration
because it it squeezes the knowledge out
of the action value functions and then
no other
changes will happen okay if i wanted to
do more iterations the value would need
to change
okay but in this process we're assuming
that we're pre-computing for some set of
policies pi
and pi prime does not necessarily become
part of this and we're not going to
recompute its value necessarily
that would require extra data and that
would allow us to iterate
but in all of the results that i will
show we only do this once
so here's a little illustration this is
a little grid world task where you have
an agent
there's red objects and blue objects and
we're going to
uh consider for example uh one reward
function which is
uh being attracted by red objects okay
and another reward function which is
being attracted by blue objects and then
a reward function that
likes red but not blue okay and so
one way to think about this is uh that
we have the features which are
red and blue objects and we're going to
make a linear weighting
over these features so w1 is a it's a
weight vector that says i like red
and i'm i mean different to blue w2 says
i like blue
and w3 says we like red we don't like
blue
okay and the the little shaded areas are
showing you trajectories
that these policies will produce if the
agent is this little yellow circle
okay
so one interesting thing to note here is
that you can think of w essentially as a
preference function over features
okay that's very clear uh in this
example which features do you like which
which features do you not like and we
can pre-train policies essentially
maximizing those features ahead of time
so in a lot of the experiments for
example
we pre-trained pi one and pi two
okay which are these two policies that
like red objects and blue objects and we
use them as the basis for transfer
the way that we're going to do the
transfer piece is by doing
gp and gpi
now there's there's a couple more
interesting things to think about
one is what if we actually don't know
the reference vector w okay
well that problem is easy to solve by
regression right we can just take tuples
state action and reward these are single
states tuples and we've made the
assumption
that the reward is a linear function uh
of uh you know if we consider uh phi
being given and so we can just solve a
regression
and you can put in you know squared
error or any of your favorite uh
regression targets here and
solve for uh w tilde here so think of
this as the
task inference step now
what if we don't also know the right
features
well then maybe what we need to do is to
look at multiple tasks
okay and so here we consider a problem
where we're
learning both the features phi tilde as
well
as the weightings w tilde okay
and it's just a sort of a nested regress
and notice that to solve this problem
you can make any arbitrary choices about
uh phi tilde so in particular we can
choose that to be a neural net and build
complexity
when i'm going to jump in just to say
you've got about four minutes left
sounds good thank you okay so here are
some
uh the environment that i was showing
you before uh we can train q learning to
solve this environment
uh we're looking at task w3 so you like
red
you don't like blue uh we've pre-trained
policies that like red and like blue
we've pre-trained them with five uh
times ten to the power five
uh time steps and we've returned uh
their
um both the policy as well as the
successor features
um q-learning here the horizontal dashed
line you can think of that as the
optimal performance this has been
trained by
ten to the six sampled transitions okay
um and uh now we can do gp and gpi or
you
you can train uh q learning from scratch
on the new task
okay and so q learning of course
eventually
will will reach the optimum performance
but it will take a very long time
whereas if i know the w
then of course we can take our two
policies and do gp and gpi immediately
and we get this horizontal blue line in
the graph
and if we don't know w we need a few
time steps
to get some data to do the regression
and so that's the little dashed blue
line here
and you can see that this converges
really really quickly
the other thing you have to notice is
that
we are making a trade-off between the
quality of the final solution
and the sample size okay these processes
are extremely fast right
orders of magnitude faster than q
learning
but of course they're not going to end
up with the same performance as you're
learning if you have enough
transitions then you should do q
learning in this particular example and
you get
to the right solution but we're making
this trade off very quickly
we are in the very small sample regime
the other picture is sort of zooming in
at the very beginning of this trajectory
and actually looking at learning both w
as well as
phi and phi of different dimensions and
you can see that this problem is
actually quite easy
again this is essentially a supervised
learning problem
and so we can do this really really
quickly
this graph here is a little bit
mysterious but what we're trying to show
is the effect of the policy set
okay on this process obviously you know
intuitively the policies matter
and figure a is looking at uh
some different initial policies all of
the policy classes are disjoint and the
red green and blue
lines here are each a policy class
and the w's that you see are the ws for
the policies that have been included in
these sets
okay and the dashed lines are just you
learning after
seeing amounts of data um and again when
we're doing gp gpi this is an immediate
process because in this case we're
providing w so it's
zero shot requires no no further data
and what you can see
and the farther away you are from the
center the more reward you're getting
okay and so what you can see is that yes
there are
some policies like you know this uh
this blue set for example provides good
performance on all different tasks
okay other sets are perhaps a little bit
less good
figure b is a situation where we start
with one policy and then we keep adding
policies so each of these sets
has more and more policies added to them
and again performance increases but in
this case
at least at the beginning your
performance will be best
if you're looking at policies that are
similar uh to the ones that you had in
the training set but really performance
can be good
for quite different policies that are
from from a spectrum of different
locations and in this case
um the other thing that we can do is
actually infer the preference vector so
infer the w
uh because uh the agent's preferences
really could vary over time so if you
imagine this example that i was talking
about
and imagine that the task is always to
pick up the object that
appears more in the grid world so if
there's more red objects you want red
but otherwise you want blue
then actually you should modify your
preferences over time
and of course we can think of this as
yet another reinforcement learning
problem but at a higher level the level
that chooses over w
and so here we made an instantiation of
this idea
where we just discretize w in each
component you if you can have a one or
zero or a minus 1
and we can do q learning to choose this
higher level preference vector
and then we can do gpe gpi at any given
instant
given the w w that we have
to decide what the policy should be and
this is the green line in these graphs
and you can see that that is
better that than than q learning
actually in this case with the amount of
data that we're showing
and it's also better than any fixed uh
preference
and you can also do this uh sort of
uh one more step with temporal
abstraction so this is a paper we had at
neurips last year
uh where we presented uh the option
keyboard architecture
and the idea here is that we're also
gonna do gpn gpi
but this time instead of having policies
we're going to have options that include
termination conditions
and if you think of termination as
another action
you can kind of see that you can put
options in this process very naturally
initially this this idea of the option
keyboard was suggested by rich sutton
but basically we instantiated it um
and here are some results actually
with an agent that is a continuous
control agent in in an arena
it uh trains some options in this
red blue and green direction but then
using gpn gpi we can actually solve
tasks that require the agent to move in
any of these yellow pie
directions and one thing that i want to
point out
is that compared to usual option methods
which are restricted
to calling options from the given set in
this case
we are actually allowed uh
you know to to have other primitive
actions because we're doing gpi and
again gpi might
decide to choose actions that are in
none of the policies that we have
and so the results that we can obtain
with this uh method which is this blue
curve here
are better than uh than results that can
be obtained just by calling options
so i'm going to wrap up very quickly
i've presented some very general tools
for using policies and predictions
uh that can be quickly uh
combined uh to uh to provide solutions
to new problems
again you should view this as a
trade-off between a way to make a
trade-off between the solution quality
and the sample complexity
that may be useful for continual
learning never-ending learning kind of
problems there are lots of interesting
open problems here
the biggest one in my head is what is a
good behavior basis for a particular
class of environments
i've showed you that the the policies
that we are using as a basis
uh do make an impact but we don't
actually know
uh what would be an optimal initial
policy set
there's also an issue of calibration in
some sense because reward scales may be
very different
uh here we have some control because
we're assuming
that the rewards are obtained through
this linear combination of our features
and so we can essentially calibrate
through the feature layer
but in general that may be a problem and
i would really like
us to also get more empirical experience
with this method so
stop here big up to take questions
fantastic thank you dona let's open the
floor up for questions we're about five
minutes for questions
maybe i'll start then doing that um oh
there's also something in the q
a but uh i'm not sure i can
i'll uh how about i will uh
this is a number suit i will uh remember
fireman
asks why perform generalized policy
improvement
only for one step um so specifically
can't we add the new eye prime to the
list of policies evaluate it and add it
sort of build this dictionary of
policies incrementally
absolutely and so the this uh this
picture
picture be here this is basically what
we did
is we build the dictionary of policies
incrementally
adding policies uh this is going to cost
more data because any time that i add a
policy i'm going to have to compute
its successor feature representation and
so uh
in principle either i need to remember
data from before i do of policy learning
or i need to run the new policy and get
it successful feature
presentation because i need a value
function for it so that's the trade-off
if we if we were open to that then we
can absolutely grow the policy set
over time and then continue doing policy
improvement and have a generalized
process as a normal dynamic programming
remember you can speak now as well or
see alec has a question so maybe we can
start there
right yeah sure thanks uh thanks for
promoting me on to be on the panel
so i have another question doing right i
mean it's a very good
work i liked i read some of the papers
so
uh like here you take the supreme or
maximum
over all the policies but does it make
sense to maybe just take over a subset
of policies
maybe those policies that are somehow
more similar to kind of
make fight crimes that are specialized
to policies that are
somehow similar i don't know if it makes
sense or not but
yeah so in principle you could restrict
the supreme to a subset of big pi
and then you would have an improvement
with respect to that subset
now the similarity here is
a little bit of a tricky thing because
what you want like you could get for
example very good generalization
from policies that are very different
than the optimal policy for your tasks
so
if you imagine that you have two
policies that pull you around the x and
y direction
and the third policy should go away from
x and y
right these two policies are very
different but they're good enough to
push you in z
right right and so there's this other
effect that's a little bit harder to
quantify
i think it's a it's a really interesting
thing to think about and it does go back
to
this issue of what's a good behavior
basis uh because you can consider this
behavior base as given at the beginning
or you
if you were to construct the set of
policies incrementally
you could also think of which policies
you want to include at every step
okay thanks
hello so it was more more of a comment
than a question
um you know like you pointed out adding
adding the latest policy every time to
the mixture has
has the problem that you have to
estimate more and more value functions
um a slightly different way of
allowing yourself to do more than one
step of policy improvement is to
uh think of really using this as a
part of a par part of the
of the gradient direction you estimate
in a policy gradient uh
method where you take a few steps on
policy
and then when you want to use a terminal
value function instead of using
the on policy one you use uh sort of the
max function coming out of generalized
policy evaluation
and um we recently did some work using
uh this style of
approach uh i mean we were thinking
about this more in the imitation
learning style settings
uh but it's uh same policy improvement
and we found um that way to be
quite beneficial especially if the um
policies you're improving upon
are fairly suboptimal for the task at
hand
yeah yeah that's a that's a great point
and uh yeah i'll have to i'll have to
read your work
uh but yes i i agree with your comment
emma next very interesting work um i
i was excited to hear the talk um i had
a question about whether or not
this issue of sort of which basis
functions we use for the policies
do you think maybe some of the recent
work in reward free exploration might be
relevant there
if we have very little assumptions or if
we think there might be very different
types of reward functions we don't later
i wonder if some of that work might
generate a series
of policies designed to sort of cover
the space that we could compute the
successor
representations for in the function
approximation setting
yeah that's a very interesting point and
i think that's one
possible solution um
one of the the restrictions is we would
ideally so either we would like the
space of policies to be small
or we would like the policies to be very
related because if the
if big pi is very large then taking that
max
may become expensive and so
you know i think this is where it
becomes interesting to think
like you know how do you build that in
like if you if
if all i we gave you is five policies
which ones
and clearly the the policy set may
depend
also also on on this size the
alternative is also
to to consider the space of policies
actually to be some other
kind of you know might be a continuous
compact set that has some special
structure
so that max's can be taken but i i'm not
sure like that seems like a very hairy
problem right now
so we're you know right now firmly and
uh you know
a small discrete set of policies but
yeah the pointer is really good
great maybe we'll uh wrap this up now to
move on to shum thank you so